les yeux ont du mal à capter le langage
un peu chelou et zarbi d'été si c'est le
thème de notre page spéciale ce langage
un peu particulier que vous connaissez
peut-être pas très bien alors je vais
répéter les yeux ont du mal à capter le
langage se louer zarbi d'été si et je
traduis sous le contrôle de claude
hagège agrégé de lettres
je traduis donc les parents ont du mal à
comprendre le langage un peu bizarres
des cités eh bien figurez vous qu'un
professeur à la sorbonne s'est intéressé
de près à ce phénomène il a même publié
un dictionnaire dictionnaire que je vous
présente ça s'appelle comment tu
tchatche dictionnaire du français
contemporain des cités avec une préface
justement de claude hagège que nous
recevrons dans quelques instants
et bien ce professeur s'est rendu dans
les cités justement pour étudier un peu
le langage qu'on y trouve
valérie astruc et jean-paul chaussée
l'ont suivi sur son lieu de travail
fabien ma femme et moi on va faire un
tri blanc il a quitté la sorbonne pourra
traîner ses oreilles en banlieue ce
professeur de linguistique étudie
l'argot des sites durant toute une année
ces jeunes nous ont servi de l'îlot pour
réaliser un dictionnaire pas comme les
autres et on jugera à paris on joue sur
paris paname sur pamiers vous sur paname
sur paname de congés bousso sopalin pour
aller on te bois
alors on met du coup dans la turbo et
son apport en tailleur voilà ça c'est
pour des personnes qui disent à une
voiture qui lui mais s'il vous plaît
trop mais s'il ya plus de trop balayer
basse et une fonction une fonction au
possible fonction identitaire c'est sûr
ça fait le groupe
c'est aussi la fonction
du jeu ludique à une part là-dedans et
entend le cryptage
quand tu es dans le métro mais pas trop
être entendu par les autos qu'on va
parler dans une langue n'est pas
forcément une langue circulant à l'école
en classe et à parler français la preuve
mais dans la course je parle car c'est
comme pour le morse et un code les
militaires il utilise un code pour pas
se faire comprendre aux autres ben nous
c'est un vrai d'entrée nous pour pas se
faire entendre
c'est tout ça et là ça va pas plus loin
on a peur bret
elle engage sans important ce n'est pas
l'avis du polo sera donc go gourette à
la sorbonne ces séminaires explore
l'origine de chaque mot référence à
l'arabe une vieille argot français le
professeur a recensé plus de 2000
expression circulant dans les cités co
et terme des banlieues où certains cas
par exemple qui sont très connus comme
meuf kof qui vont même jusqu'à rentrer
dans le dictionnaire sont intégrés dans
la langue de tous les jours toutes les
façons de parler son bond pour
communiquer alors dès qu'ils sont bank
pour communiquer alors voilà l'intérêt
de les étudier
d'après ce professeur l'argot des
soutiers ne menace pas notre sherlock
française bien au contraire il enrichit
de mots variés donne naissance à une
culture europe celle du rap
[Musique]